les jours se suivent et se ressemblent
rares sont les stations services
approvisionnaient en carburant que déjà
les files d'attente s'allongent parfois
sur plusieurs centaines de mètres la
police a été appelée en renfort pour
fluidifier le trafic et apaiser les
tensions et incivilités si besoin
Florent Clavel
sur cette route de longues files de
voitures face à face
leur objectif cette station-service
récemment réapprovisionnée en carburant
et au milieu un arbitre ce policier
municipal appelé en renfort par la
police nationale pour gérer la
circulation ça reste pas évident parce
que les gens viennent du côté gauche
côté droit et tout le monde veut rentrer
et tout le monde est ne peut pas rentrer
en même temps donc si vous voulez le
problème c'est que là on est obligé de
faire passer les voitures une par une
les gens j'irai prioritaires qui passent
donc ça reste assez difficile quand même
une présence policière qui rassure les
automobilistes
et tout se passe bien on sait pas ça
fait combien de temps que vous attendez
là un petit quart d'heure on a eu de la
chance on a été dirigé par la police
municipale donc du coup ça s'est bien
passé dans cet autre station essence de
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps le responsable
sécurité cette fois épaulé par la police
nationale si fonctionnaire présente de
14 à 16 heures pour éviter toute tension
surtout de la civilité c'est pas trop
voilà et comme on fait une des voies
prioritaire pour le personnel
hospitalier on a toujours des gens qui
essayent de forcer et du coup c'est vrai
que depuis qu'ils sont là ça se passe
beaucoup mieux et on les remercie
fortement d'être présent de quoi ramener
un peu de sérénité dans une période
stressante pour les automobilistes et
les salariés des stations services